fee of 20th century British comic
novelist PG Woodhouse from London
observer literary editor Robert McCrum
the program is 45 minutes thank you very
much I think this is the kind of club
that would have liked to have been a
member of PG would happen I first met
when I was about 10 at the time I was at
an English prep school and I started
with the mic and Smith books which made
a lot of sense
are you the bully says comrade Smith to
Mike Jackson on first encounter the
pride of the school or the boy who is
led astray and takes to drink instead
chapter 16 with Mike I was poked Bertie
Jeeves
Lord Emsworth of mr mulliner would come
later Woodhouse I think it's fair to say
it became part of my unconscious and
indeed but the part of the unconscious
about any English boy of my generation
about five years ago however when when I
read my ear off my book about my stroke
I find him creeping into the first
chapter his remark about the two ways to
write a book seemed curiously apt one he
said in a famous sentence is a sort of
musical comedy with without music the
other is going right deep down into life
and not carrying it down my ear off was
all about going deep down by contrast
Woodhouse alive has been much closer to
musical comedy when wood has within his
prime of the right of the 1920s and 30s
The Observer newspaper which I work was
one of his principal champions so it's
appropriate that Woodhouse alive should
have begun with the books pages of The
Observer on Sunday the 30th of May 1999
about five years ago I was a rigid
column about the latest batch of
penguins Woodhouse reissues these were I
wrote a selection of his best work that
confirms him I said at the end of the
century is a comic writer of sheer
genius then I made a very serious gaffe
alas I concluded there's never been the
properly researched biography of
man unbeknownst me at that very moment
Penguin Books was in the process of
looking drab wood has biographer my
article was passed back to the wood has
a state and a few months later I found I
was doing this job and here we are I
confess I've never written a biography
before and I wasn't nervous about it
because wood house is a national
treasure
the English feel rather proprietorial
about as a novice have become quite a
student of biographical technique where
do you start what point of view do you
adopt towards your subject how do you
relate the work to the life and so on my
method is the method of the King of
Hearts advice of the Mad Hatter in Alice
in Wonderland begin at the beginning you
want to come to the end and stop that's
not all of course there's a bit in one
of the story collections very good jeez
where Bertie Wooster says the great
thing on these occasions as G's will
tell you is to get a toehold on the
psychology of the individual study the
individual and you'll bring home the
bacon so I've been studying the
individual and I hope I brought home the
bacon in my biography I've made a point
of never forgetting that first and last
Woodhouse is a sublimely funny writer
Michael George says but I wish to
discover that alcohol is a food well in
advance of modern enlightened thought
of another uncle he writes Uncle Tom
always looked a bit like a pterodactyl
with a secret sorrow while of uncle
Alaric he says phew coots could have had
less hair and any walrus would be
impressed of a starter which he was
puffing and I could spend most of the
night quoting from Winterson you'd be in
stitches and we would have a lovely
evening but it wouldn't get as much
further forward in the life so I'm the
carom of the life genealogy is very
important to it house versa is always
getting on about William the Conqueror
in the Middle Ages and that's for one
very good reason Woodhouse is a funny
English name with anglo-saxon roots and
belongs to a family that goes back
almost as far as 1066 famously the name
Woodhouse is not pronounced the way it
looks the first meaning of wood is
related to trees the second derivation
gives out of one's mind insane lunatic
Lysander in A Midsummer Night's Dream
complains of being wood within this wood
there's also an obviously old English
term wood words meaning a wild man of
the woods a satyr a form that's a bad
beginning for a great humorist he was
born in England in 1881 the son of a
colonial judge and christened Pelham
Grendel this frightful label in his
description came out as plum or plummy
and is how he still known a serious wood
has found across the world to this day
he was born in the same year as Picasso
and Bartok just after Einstein and
ianforster the year before James Joyce
of Virginia Woolf he was part of a
generation that would challenge every
ethnic of the world around them music
language perspective even time itself
but Woodhouse was not revolutionary
either by inheritance or temperament his
answer to the turmoil of his time was to
escape to create an English rural
paradise to give his division readers a
lunatic version of their society
families that the wood houses were the
people who ran the country who served as
MPs
Headmaster's and district officers as
boys they went to public schools so that
for their preparation in the duties of
Empire as grown men they enlisted in the
Imperial civil servant service and
joined clubs in power mal where they
read the times and relaxed over coffee
cigars and copies of punch in punch
there are only three classes the
frivolous toss to wear top hats and put
up the lower orders the respectable
middle classes who are sparta better
things and the age dropping working
classes who Chuck half bricks of the
carriages of their superiors this
hierarchy was part of what houses
unconscious inheritance in this story
the Metropolitan touch he described the
audience of Bingley littles village for
production of what hurt wing as follows
the first few rows of the audience were
occupied by the nibs then came a dense
squash of what you might call the lower
middle classes at the back we came down
with the jerk in the social scale this
end of the hall being given up to a
collection of frankly tough eggs so
first and last would house was a
Victorian English public school boy as
George Orwell who was a lifelong fan
wrote in 1946 a thing that people often
forget about Peter Wood has his novels
is how long had the better known of them
were written like many middle-class
Victorians and indeed like all well wood
house grew up a kind of orphan up to the
age of 15 he saw his mother for a total
of six months the first time he met her
as a young boy he thought she was just
another aunt she was he said virtually a
stranger
I think this had three important lasting
consequences first the separation from
his family made him solitary left to his
own devices he became an avid reader
he says somewhere that he read the
Pope's translation of the Iliad when he
was just six as a lifelong reader he
developed an instinctive taste for
fantasy and a gift for rearranging
reality to suit his purposes
second the absence
parental organization and the loss of a
fable step family loss of a stable
family life made him look for routine
throughout his adult years he showed an
abnormal attachment to routine early
rising regular exercise lunch and dinner
at a certain time a walk in the
afternoon the first cocktail and so on
thirdly the pain of separation made him
a master of English stoicism the stiff
upper lip his childhood was fairly
dreadful by modern standards
Woodhouse pre Freudian and deeply
Victorian says it went like a breeze
from start to finish for three
essentials for an autobiography he wrote
are this author should have had a I have
should have had an eccentric father a
miserable childhood and a hell of a time
in his public school but I enjoyed none
of these advantages
my father was as normal as rice pudding
in my school days at Dulwich was just
six years of unbroken bliss it was a
childhood spent apart from at school in
the company of arms would his vision of
art is not flattering they are he says
like mastodons bellowing across primeval
swamps his two most famous fictional
arts the north and south poles of
victorian Antonis art Dalia and our
Agatha the pest of Tom Street aunt Delia
on the other hand is the jolly one
according to Bertie she afford more
Liberty than I have ever heard a woman
care for if there had been a Nile she
would have rolled in it she gave the
impression of a hyena who has just had a
good one from another hyena aren't
Agatha who is based on his mother sister
mary is altogether more imposing with an
eye like a management fish
Bertie says when I was a kid at school
she was always able to turn me inside
out with a single glance there's about
five foot nine of our bhagava topped off
of the beaky nose and eagle eye and lots
of gray hair and the general effect is
pretty formidable as Bodie says it is no
use telling me that there are bad and
good ants at the core they are all alike
sooner or later out pops the cloven hoof
and I think there's a good degree of his
portative of ants taken from his mother
as well as well as his actual answer in
uneasy money
Woodhouse Wright's boyhood like measles
is one of those complaints which a young
man should catch young and have done
with but his own boy boyhood is vital to
an animal to an understanding of the
mature man he found his first real home
at the age of 13 when he went to Dulwich
to him the experience of boarding with
other boys was unbroken bliss in some
ways he never really grew up as he said
in 1947 I'm a bad case of Arrested
Development mentally I seem not to
progressed a step since I was 18 when he
wrote this room but he was a listen
young listen young trickling of some 66
summers and indeed when people described
meeting him in later all through his
life he was always described as being
like a large boy he was very tall about
my height probably it may be a bit
taller and large and fit every day of
his life he did what he called the daily
dozen which was it selects not
calisthenic exercises popularized after
the first world war he left down it at
the turn of the new century the Boer War
was at its height Queen Victoria had
just celebrated her Diamond Jubilee at
school
a clever boil of the precocious command
of lesson in Greek would have been
destined for Oxford but it was not to be
his father recently retired from East
and living on a rupee pension said he
could not afford it he decreed that
young plum should earn a living so
straight from school Woodhouse went to
work at the London branch at the Hong
Kong and Shanghai Blanc known today as
the HSBC it was a crushing blow the
cruel climax to a loveless childhood
still Woodhouse became utterly at home
in the mid-water metropolis Wood has his
London was a place where aristocrats
chaste actresses
wear American money pursued British
class where bookmakers and varma is
mixed on equal
with cabinet ministers once he started
work in the city it was a race against
time he had to establish himself as a
freelance writer before the bank sent
him out east of Hong Kong from the Far
East and these were the apprentice years
1900 1982 when he developed the
forwardable daily writing writing
routine that stayed with him to the end
of his life while working at the Hong
Kong Shanghai bank he had a lucky break
he got a job as a columnist on a London
evening paper The Globe in 1982 he quit
the bag and set out as he put it on my
wild alone to make his name as a writer
he was happy on the globe
the hours were ideal once he had found
his copy by the noon deadline he was
free to go home to work on his novel he
also learned to the clatter of the
newsroom the invaluable art of writing
under deadline pressure in any
environment and to the end of his life
he retained an anvil facility for
writing in the most difficult
circumstances ocean liners boat trains
even as it turned out prison so over the
first years of for the first 25 years of
his life on his wildly on his first and
foremost he was first and foremost a
journalist motivated by deadlines or the
promise of a check the same month he
left the bank his first novel the
Pothunters was published it's still in
print that's almost exactly 100 years
ago he was just 21 years old but he had
yet to fulfill his ambition of going to
the United States of America which was
to him the land of romance and he didn't
get to America for bookish reasons but
because he was a keen amateur boxer a
damage he fought and fought regularly in
the amateur ring and it was boxing not
books the first brought into the USA he
sailed the Atlantic in the spring of
1904 to see Kidd McCoy fight
Philadelphia Jack O'Brien in a
heavyweight bout he fell in love with
America at first sight
to say that New York came up with
advanced billing he once wrote would be
the baldest understatement being there
was like being in heaven without going
to all the bother and expense of dying
after a month in New York he returned to
London and he discovered in his trip
that were has done wonders for its value
as a freelance I was a man who counted
he rated my income rose like a rocketing
pheasant as well as his American
experience it's important to stress
would have this Edwardian youth as a
young man Woodhouse was steeped in the
boys writers of the age and addicted to
the stories of Arthur Conan Doyle
published monthly in the Strand and some
say the relationship of Jeeves and
Wooster was inspired by Holmes and
Watson he was certainly determined to
sell his work in New York as well as in
London and from 1904 to the end of his
life would have perfected the art of
transatlantic trading selling a literary
version of America to British readers
and an affectionate caricature of
Britain to Americans and both versions
were filtered through the rosy rosy
spectacles of his imagination this makes
him I think rather modern Wood has his
talent for selling a version of Britain
to America was emulated a century later
but the makers of Four Weddings and a
funeral and Notting Hill so Jeeves the
world-famous Butler actually made his
first appearance in New York in 1916 in
The Saturday Evening Post I find it
curious would have once wrote now that
I've written so much about him to recall
how softly ungrammatically Jeeves first
entered my little world on that occasion
he spoke just two lines the first was
mrs. Gregson D'Souza the second very
good sir which suitably were
it was only some time later that the
man's qualities dawned upon me and I
still blush to think that the offhand
way I treated him at our first encounter
Jeeves
takes his name from the Warwickshire
County cricketer the medium pace as a
pitcher Persie Jeeves who was killed on
the Somme in July 1916 as a gentleman's
gentleman Jeeves could not be further
removed from the mud and slaughter of
Flanders and he was deeply Edwardian
Woodhouse had been exploring such a
character in his fiction for many years
in writing about Butler's as a young boy
he said that he had lived on the fringe
of the battle of belt a gentleman's
gentleman of course is not a butler but
he's more than a mere valid Jeeves is
above and beyond such creatures he is
nothing if not unique Jeeves is an on
parade but he will rooster tells his
readers that Kives stands alone there is
who says none like you none I am with
Bertie
personally I can never tear up Jeeves
there's his absolute discretion
it was the soft cough of jeeves's which
always reminds me of a very old sheep
Cleary its throat on a distant mountain
top there's his mysterious gift of
movement he never walks Gees never walks
he floats or pops or filters or paws
silently into Bertie's presence Jeeves
entered or cups I should say shimmered
into the room and then there's his
benign calm
Jeeves doesn't smile on this occasion
because he never does but the lips
twitch slightly the corners in the eyes
benevolent Jeeves is always on hand to
counsel and advise at the really crucial
moment in Berta's life and it's worth
saying on pass oh I think that Bertie is
a unique figure Bertie Wooster's a
unique figure in the calendar English
the English literature I cannot think
I'd love to have anyone here can think
of a hero a central figure in any major
English fiction who is purely good
purely innocent he's pure innocent
there's the worst he's ever done is
steal the policeman's helmet
well Pantera or puncture our hot water
with a stick but Danny needs along the
end the element of Jeeves care inside it
with another turning point in December
of 1915 the first night of a Broadway
musical would have marooned in New York
during the first world war bumped into
an old friend from his Edwardian London
days the composer Jerome Kern who was
with there with his writing partner guy
Bolton in no time at all at all
Woodhouse and Bolton and curl formed in
George Catherines phrase the trio of
musical Fame these three young men
transformed the American musical into
the form you know today with a
succession of hit shows leave it to Jane
a lady lady and Sally and many others in
1917 Wood has her know lesson five
shared running on Broadway a record that
has never been surpassed muster the
irritation I've must tell you after such
a Tim Rice if by some mischance would
has had been run out of run over by a
bus in the 1920s his a [ __ ] would
have made much more of his work the
lyricist on Broadway thought of his
fiction to degree perhaps not
sufficiently appreciated before without
that much of his trade in the theater
he had yet to find the colossal audience
he achieved in the 30s as I have said he
himself like to describe his fiction as
a sort of musical comedy without music
and I hope that my biography
convincingly demonstrates the close
connection between these American
musicals and his best fiction once the
Great War was over Woodhouse was already
an unofficial American living in Great
Neck a neighbor of F scott Fitzgerald
and Enrico Caruso for the next 20 odd
years he criss crossed the Atlantic on
the Cunard Line like any business class
commuter his work they rooted in the
English country house in the London club
or Sarah frontier prohibition in the
Jazz Age it became infiltrated by
American characters senators impresarios
bootleggers and American slang words
like Ronnie Gazoo hotsy-totsy and bum's
rush
Woodhouse lived and died in America but
travel constantly all his life escaping
from London he experimented with the
Riviera with Hollywood twice and finally
settling in the 2k with ultimately
disastrous consequences by the end of
the 1920s he was hugely rich in world
famous the New York Times reported his
movements like a rock star the climax is
an organization came in 1930 and he was
invited by MGM to write film scripts in
Hollywood he wrote it was an era when
Elia Mannix when only a man of
exceptional ability and emulation could
keep from getting signed up by a studio
in some capacity or other I happen to be
engaged as a writer he went out to
California on a salary a staggering
salary of $100,000 for six months work
several million dollars a day he worked
with George Gershwin with the Boy Wonder
Irving Thalberg Fitzgerald's Last Tycoon
Fred Astaire and many others I must say
that none of the films to which
Woodhouse contributed I remember today
but he did get something out of the
experience he transformed his adventures
in Tinseltown into novels like the life
of the Balkans and comic fantasies like
laughing gasps Woodhouse's Hollywood
became as much an innocent paradise as
Blandings all the drones Club populated
by spendthrift English peers
power-hungry movie moguls and dizzy
blondes at the same time he never sees
writing brilliantly as much for
Americans as for Britons about his
private English fantasy world and in
1938 he wrote what I think is one of his
finest novels the care of the Wooster's
which contains that immortal sentence he
spoke with a certain what is it in his
voice and I could see that if not
actually disgruntled he was far from
being gruntled
in 1939 year the war broke out he was
ordered a deal it from oxygen university
and he was about as faint as it was
possible to be as a writer more famous
than any writer living today his
celebrity was just Universal as an
initial humorist but ironically it was
Woodhouse's american notice that was the
ruin of him in 1940 partly to avoid
taxation and partly to be news beloved
dunnage he was living in the villa in
the 2k a French seaside resort just
south of Calais and Dunkirk when France
fell in May 1940 Woodhouse was arrested
as an enemy alien in occupied territory
along with all the other English expats
in France he was sent to an internment
camp in a formal lunatic asylum in Upper
Silesia in what is now Poland many
antennas were wrecked by the experience
some weren't mad others committed
suicide almost none was unscathed that
would house Victorian English stoic
annex public school by simply thrived
campy told a friend was really great fun
and he said at the time if this is upper
silesia
who knows what louis i'll is ask me like
despite the extraordinary privations he
kept up his routine and found comfort in
his fantasy world remarkably he
completed money in the bank and started
full moon during the internment his
internment and his finest novel for many
join the morning was completed in
Germany before the war ended and what's
fascinating about these books is that
despite living through these terrible
years in Nazi Germany you cannot find in
these books a reference a simile an
allusion to what's kept going on it's
it's all the fantasy world probably
probably why I think everyone did defend
one which I've identified in my book but
there are very few and anyone else any
other writer having gone through that
experience I'm quite convinced would
have found ways of alluding to what did
happen to them in his or her work just
before his 60th birthday in accordance
with the Geneva Convention this is a
technical point he was released Berlin
from the camp now in camp his American
fans America despite of it was a newt
this is 1941 America was still a neutral
country they're not in the war in camp
his many American bands had written to
him by the score and on his release in
June and 41 to answer their letters in
to reassure his public that he was alive
in the world he made five radio
broadcast from Berlin it was a terrible
blunder that would house the Victoria
who saw a European conflict as a kind of
a way match never understood it he never
tried to blame anyone but himself he
read to a friend I made an ass of myself
and I must pay the penalty looked at the
first today the broadcasts are light
humorous descriptions of life in camp
not more here for example as the
beginning of the talk entitled how to be
an internee
now it's very important I think at this
point just to stress that when these
broadcasts were first made in in the
last week of June 1941 the war was going
about as badly for England and the
Allies as it could possibly be going
Hitler the Germans of pity winning the
German army was sweeping through the
the war in the Atlantic gone great badly
America was not yet in the war
and say we were really up against it and
that Pop's plum PG woodhouse in Berlin
with broadcast service frivolousness
breathtaking fearlessness and they
wonder that people got upset here's the
beginning of the first lecture this was
in type of had to be interning young men
starting out in life have often asked me
how can I become an antenna well there
are several methods my own was to buy a
villa in the 2k on the coast of France
and stay there until the Germans came
along this is probably the best and
simplest system you buy the better the
German through the rest even his account
of the very marked in the 2k which was
endlessly created against him shows
evidence only of a comic writer trying
to get a laugh
I was sterling on the lawn my wife one
morning when she lowered her voice and
said don't look now but there comes the
German army and there they were
a fine body of men rather prettily
dressed in green carrying machine guns
and more and much water the same effect
but not a word pro or anti that the
regime just jokes about camp life
his mistake was not what he said but
that he allowed himself to appear on
Nazi radio at the very moment Germany
appeared to have been in the war there
was an international outcry the British
press particularly launched a witch-hunt
and disgrace followed swiftly it was
impossible to return to Britain and he
spent the rest of the war first in
Berlin and then in Paris finally in the
spring of 1947 he sail for New York an
outcast and an exile in America he
completed the mating season and this
marked the end of his golden period the
golden period which had begun in roughly
1929 with summer lightning and heavy
weather for many years after the war he
wrestled with his craft as he raised me
one of the introduction to his post-war
work the world of which I have been
writing since I was so high has gone
with the wind it is one with Nineveh and
tar in a word it has had it wit has
settled in the Hamptons on south
sure of Long Island he became in his own
words Squire Woodhouse of Remsen burg
slowly he resumed his career as a
humorous but for the rest of his life he
could never escape the accusations of
treachery and even now his name
guarantees farcical frivolity
it also contains quite unfairly dubious
collaboration is amande pro-fascist
sympathies and I stressed this point
because while I was working on this book
people would say to what do you do and I
say I'm right here buying for PG
woodhouse and they'd say two things they
always had the same two things first of
all they'd say that must be a lot of fun
which of course is true it's also a lot
of work and then they would say wasn't
he a traitor collaborationist a fascist
an art seal so some version of that lie
was it's tucked him three influential in
three influential English friends
writers did their best to acquit him of
the charges of pro-fascist sympathies
Malcolm Muggeridge
says it wasn't that he was otherworldly
or unworldly as much as that he was a
worldly wit has his true offense was to
have disinterested himself in the war
George Orwell wrote a long and famous
essay in defense of P G Wodehouse which
had never been bettered Orwell wrote the
idea that in 1941 he consciously aided
that the Nazi propaganda machine is
untenable and ridiculous his moral
outlook was that of a public school one
according to the public school code
treachery in town of war is that
unforgivable of all sins and finally
there's evening war who made a broadcast
on the BBC on what has his 80th birthday
entitled an act of atonement and
reparation and two famous passages I
read she was I've expected so much about
him for Woodhouse
there's been no fall of man no
Aboriginal calamity his characters have
never tasted the forbidden fruit they
are still in Eden the gardens of
landings cars are that original garden
from which we were all exiled the chef's
gonna tell prepares ambrosia for the
Immortals of high Olympus mr. wood has
his world never stale he has made a
world for us to live in and delight him
he worked to the very end of his life he
wrote every day is likely work to the
end of it
his last unfinished novel sunset the
planning was found by his bedside after
his death aged 93 on some Valentine's
Day 1975 work in progress from a
committed writer his massive Victorian
to stairs is inscribed the names of his
most famous creations Smith Bertie was -
Jeeves
Lord Emsworth mr mulliner and he's
buried not in Britain on the South Shore
of Long Island an American citizen it is
now a generation since Wood has his
death and a succession of new wood has
land martyrs in view the 100th
anniversaries of his first books books
like the plot hunters love among the
chickens Mike something fresh the list
goes on and on they're all in print
remarkably and there among understood
made by a new generation today the
wartime scandals seen in a longer
perspective no longer clouds the readers
approach to his work it can be seen as a
disastrous blunder that reflects on the
author but not on his books his fame
will never again reach the peaks of the
thirties but his comic vision has an
absolutely secure place in the English
literary imagination - created not one
but as many as five great characters
Bertie Jeeves Lord Emsworth aunt Agatha
and Smith who require their introduction
places him in a very select group of
writers led by Shakespeare and Dickens
and some enthusiasts have tried to
compare into these writers but the
comparison in Maya Butte is not really
fly Woodhouse was a miniaturist
his work is not like those in many ways
Wood has his much closer in spirit to
Jane Austen like her
Woodhouse plays his characters in a just
vanished society but one moreover whose
reality was transformed by her
remarkable powers of fantasy and
imagination into something timeless and
permanent the secret of that permanence
lies in Woodhouse's surreptitious elegy
for his country behind the drones and
the manor house begins as a sweet
melancholy nostalgia for England of
innocent laughter and song and it is for
this reason I believe that wood has his
work
undisputed place in the Canon of English
literature his writing is less
vulnerable to fashion than many other
20th century contemporaries but as
popular comedy is like to be undervalued
Woodhouse understood this humorists she
wrote towards the end of his life I
looked down upon by the intelligence
here and his work I think will continue
to suffer the fate of so much light to
comic writing it will rarely be treated
with the seriousness it deserves or with
the seriousness accorded to many lesser
writers but Woodhouse would not be
dismayed for him the lightness was all
seriousness was risking seriousness
meant raising too many painful questions
either about himself or about his
society seriousness was about finding
answers which were troubling things with
painful consequences probably he sense
that there were no answers enigmatic and
elusive in his own life he was happy to
let things remain a mystery in lightness
and lunacy existence could be bearable
and the unexamined life left to its own
devices could go like a breeze
especially at crowded with incident what
we said of her Butler's and valence are
dedicated to helping old pals ignoring
the big questions then it was also what
has his genius to execute the lightness
of his stories and a language that
danced on the page like poetry marrying
the English style of the Academy with
the English slang of the suburbs with a
sprinkling of American English training
well the lightness is also a slight of
hand behind the comic mayhem of booth
had his best work horrifying as it may
seem for those for whom he's work is a
blessed escape from seriousness and
difficulty there is I believe an
inspiration that gives his significance
deprived and childhood the parental
affection and unable fully to express it
in his own life which has his lasting
subject is universal the foibles of the
human heart take away the Aberdeen
Terriers the cocktail shakers the banjos
the tartan spats the pedes the frantic
telegrams and the quest for human
connection is the worrying flywheel the
piece the intricate clockwork of his
plot sticking and makes his world go
round
Wood has often described it as an
innocent and say he was in many wedding
work many ways but were the innocents
came an exceptional good nature and a
profound humanity he believed in doing
what he called the square thing by his
fellow man and in an understated torrent
of human frailty his biggest trouble the
terrible wartime blunder sprang from the
best of motives an expression of
gratitude to readers who lightest work
and beyond that there is the work an
extraordinary body of English prose
novels stories poems films plays
reportage correspondence memoir they get
him consequence successive generations
of readers will return again and again
to his books to admire his inimitable
gifts to laugh at the follies of the
human comedy and to celebrate the magic
of an English of an English prose caught
at a singular moment between massive
culture and high art in the lives of
most great writers there are usually two
lasting themes love and work with
Woodhouse these are indistinguishable
and both prevail
thank you
but not a new q8q of the show they may
want to questions and the guys at the
back acute for this there to be a hiatus
that rent yes that hiatus well we work
out how we do this to be just a moment's
pause while c-span organizes itself and
while you organize ourselves to think of
your questions
we'll also plan to stand on microphone
will be brought to you
I have a question about your Jeeves
first sets upon the scene I thought it
was sent from the agency that mediately
prepares the hangover drink I don't
remember the words he originally floated
about its first appearance was that
different it was different a different
story
the I knew this was gonna happen
the thing about wood has usually it
tends to blur in the mind somewhat and
there are of course 100 books and many
stories but I think he does indeed
supply a honey hangover cure but not in
that first orbit the point the point the
point he was making is that he used him
as a walk on walk on character in the
story extricating young Gussie 19 in
1916 I think that was it when it was
there's only later on that he realized
with his immense value to the narrative
and then then indeed he came out with a
hangover cure which is a wonderful if
somebody's got a copy of the book I will
really die here that cured he's a great
I would like to do that actually it's
one of the great passages this is Jesus
hangover cure just say I mean just I
mean one of the things I'm trying to do
in this book is I'm trying to reclaim
him as a great English Woodhouse's a
great English stylist a ma you know for
whom every word was always in the right
place and hangover cure which comes in
the 20s bit find it was as you rightly
say it was it was one of the first
things that Jeeves does for his master
this is Jesus famous pick me up after a
hard night out but perhaps the spit part
of a second nothing happens it is as
though all nature waited breathless then
suddenly it is is it it is as if the
last campus sounded in judgment days
setting with unusual severity
bonfires burst out in all parts its
frame the abdomen becomes heavily
charged with molten lava the great wind
seems to blow to the world and the
subject is aware of something resembling
a steam hammer striking in the back of
the head and then just as you are
feeling that you ought to ring up your
lawyer and see that your affairs are in
order before it is too late the whole
situation seems to clarify the wind
drops the ears ceased to ring birds
Twitter brass band start playing the Sun
comes out over the horizon it with a
jerk and a moment later all you're
conscious of is a great piece it's a
brilliant bit of writing and that's just
one little snippet thank you to the
questions
are there any characters in Woodhouse's
novels that you think are particularly
autobiographical either characters he
identified with their characters he
would have liked to have been I think he
always thought he was Lord Emsworth
he said he does say he's always laying
full full clue but there was there's
enough in that statement and I could
back that up with the benevolence and if
he wouldn't become very analytical
I think the obsession with the pig could
stand with with I didn't bring a pig
today I'm sorry mother owned the
obsession of the pig could be made to
stand for the obsession with the work
and I think wearing he certainly like
like Lord Emsworth he liked to wear old
clothes stop about the house not what
you're not worry too much about yes and
to be detached from the front lines of
the world so I think the answer would be
Lord Emsworth although in some of the
earliest store at the school stories you
can't a strong sense of the young
Woodhouse but I think in later life Lord
Emsworth with the answer the question
looks which we say really lovely and
sporting young woman and she appears in
a lot of the stories and I wonder was
there ever anyone like that in his life
I think what happened I had didn't go
into into his marriage but he had a very
interesting man he married
Ethel Newton she was 20 she said you
went Ania turns I discovered so actually
she was 28 she shaved a year off her age
on the wedding a man on the wedding
license he married a woman who had been
made twice before her first husband a
died of cholera in India second husband
died committed suicide but anyway she
had a she had a daughter Leah Nora and
incredibly when would have married Ethel
in New York in 1914 he hadn't met the
daughter daughter was at school it was a
very strange the whole thing he was the
leonor was at school in in England and
he didn't meet her for seven months to
come when he did meet her in a stranger
he sort of fell in love with him there
was they were it was a great
relationship and I think he was close to
Leah Nora as he was to anybody and I
think what you find in the novel's
particular 20s is the character with the
female characters who are it's fated
largely cardboard cutouts initially not
they're not they're not to be
dimensional become much more interesting
and that reflect I think his closeness
to Leah Nora you Nora you may remember
was that was the dedicate a of a famous
veteran of stories way said to my
daughter Leah Nora about his unfailing
help and assistance this book would have
been finished in half the time
I think what that means is that he
actually she was his first reader and
she would read the stuff and and give
him comments and I don't think he needs
much editing but she gives you giving
feedback on his work and she died
tragically in 1944 during the war so
again part of wood has a dreadful war I
didn't get into that either but it was
some it's never side of great sadness
another one behind you sir do you think
any any of his books that he wrote after
the Second World War
rogue still to the level of the books he
wrote in the late 20s and into the 30s I
couldn't hear the first part sorry do
you think that any of the books he wrote
after the Second World War
roasted the levels that he did in late
20s and 30s though I think I may be
heretical on this I think the late
Brooks are weak and I've dealt them but
I deal with him rather briskly I mean I
don't go into them really I think
they're inferior really
he is really just coming times coming
close to plagiarizing himself and and
working old fiends and they're not fresh
they have a charm or tunnel charm but
they're not they're not the great works
by any means as I think as your question
implies I think that's that's what I've
seen
if there are no more questions we invite
you to join mr. Makram in the room
adjacent where the global bookstore from
Harvard Square has his book for sale and
of course these wine and cheese and
thank you once again very good
Robert McCrum is literary editor of
London's Observer Woodhouse a life is
published by WW Norton & Company
visit